our most directors afraid of actors I'm
not no I'm not afraid of this guy but
that's that's I go back to my point of
I'm not gonna work with those type of
people I prefer to have someone less
popular or something but I'm gonna have
the best line because if I don't have
the best time for me you know doing this
it's fun it's I don't want to feel like
it's working as soon as I feel like it's
work I don't want to do it so that's why
I need to find the right people who's
gonna have this you know friendship so
each person I need to have do I connect
friendship wise with the with them
otherwise I don't get I don't care if
you like Russell Crowe or something like
that if you're difficult to work with I
feel this year we're gonna have bump
head then now screw that and I've
learned a lot with that film I've
learned a lot casting wise and for
myself whether if you know those type of
people that I connect and doesn't
connect with and so that's why I say
with Tyler I just this this was the best
experience that I had and even other
people like first of all Noel Turin was
doing a little role in the film she was
amazing and other people like Jed Arlo
and stuff like that so yeah my casting
process is all about do I connect with
them if not your route that I want I
don't want that because I know it's
gonna be just miserable and said what do
you start to see like what are the
little signs that you go you know what
maybe this isn't the right match I think
it's just energy you're just when you
talk to that person do you have the same
vibe the same flow when when you say
something do you laugh or just something
as stupid joke and you just don't
there's like the crickets so just those
little symbol and like yeah I think you
and I get funny wise it's not working
and then I yeah you're a great actor but
then when we talk there's just some kind
of coldness and when there's I don't
know for me maybe I'm just too emotional
about it but at the same time I don't
care I just I want to have fun I want
you I wanted for him to after the best
time he doesn't want to work with a
shitty director who's just gonna yell at
him all the time even if it's for work
he's gonna you know I know he's gonna
in my back all the time about it
no no but it's it's it's crucify it so
it goes both ways
everyone who needs to have a great
experience otherwise yeah people will
and be gonna say yeah it wasn't that it
was not a fun experience and you want to
have make sure you have always the best
reputation do you think actors are
afraid of directors you knew this was
gonna come I think it's I think it's
paradoxical I think by nature yes
because they're in a position of
authority and there are as with any
authority figures well and authority
figures in certain spheres you want to
impress them you want to look good in
front of them but at a certain level
no offense mask you know but you kind of
have to have a certain irreverence at
the same time because again it goes back
to doing it for you you know I I did
want Pascal to be happy and I do want
Pascal to be happy but at the end of the
day if that's what I was rooted in if
that's what my performance was rooted in
and if that's what my my rapport on the
set was rooted in I don't think that
would be the person or the actor that I
am and so I think I don't know I the
older I get I find that real truth is is
paradoxical in nature and this is no
exception
so yeah I'm both terrified of directors
and also its role but it's but if that's
a thing it's important as long as for me
I know my vision and I know exactly what
I want even at one point it something
will stirring something and it was just
too funny funny I was like yeah
Tyler focused and I was rolling him back
because I know what I want I got I and
you know it's it's fun in game yes but
we have work to do and that's that's why
it needs a fine line of we can have a
great time but at the same time that's
work and let's make sure that you do
what I'm asking you to but I'm doing
this in a fun loving communicative
environment and if you don't have that I
think that's where he's gonna be afraid
of directors because the fact that it's
super open that you know that hey just
knock on my door come and talk to me if
you're freaking out and I'm gonna be
there I'm never gonna say you cannot
come and see me so I think that hopings
doors to let go of that fear but he does
know how to crack the whip so I did I
did some he cracks the whip
well it's difficult because you were on
a tight timeline you were in some
you know Naturals places where yeah a
storm was coming and you had very few
people to work with so I'm sure there
were some tense moments but yeah for
example that that's exact scene he was
driving the bike having the fun with
Alyssa I was just like I was freaking
out I was seeing the storm and we didn't
have like like a microphone or some
things I was driving at the Jeep trying
to run ago we were just like messing at
nothing I run in the desert trying to
refocus often you give me you give me a
64 triumph on the Bonneville Salt Flats
I'm gonna have some follow that that's
that's where he says I don't give a
but it worked
you